>>> DONALD TRUMP AND HIS TEAM
HAD A BAD TUESDAY.
THE JUSTICES CLEARED THE WAY FOR
THE HOUSE TO GET HIS TAX
RETURNS.
NEXT, QUESTIONS ABOUT HIS LEGAL
STRATEGY IN THE MAR-A-LAGO
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS CASE.
IN THAT HEARING THREE APPEALS
COURT JUDGES ALL SOUNDED
SKEPTICAL OF TRUMP'S ARGUMENT
THAT A SPECIAL MASTER SHOULD BE
KEPT IN PLACE TO SORT THROUGH
THOSE RECORDS.
PLUS, A STATE JUDGE IN NEW YORK
SET A TRIAL DATE FOR THE NEW
YORK ATTORNEY GENERAL'S SUIT
SCHEDULED FOR OCTOBER OF 2023.
JUST IN TIME FOR THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
AND THERE'S MORE.
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM WAS
FORCED TO TESTIFY BEFORE THE
SPECIAL GEORGIA GRAND JURY
INVESTIGATING TRUMP'S EFFORT TO
REVERSE THE 2020 RESULTS THERE
AND THE FORMER TRUMP CHIEF OF
STAFF MARK MEADOWS LOST A BID.
WITH ME TO SORT THROUGH IT ARE
EVAN PEREZ AND CARRIE CORDERO
AND ALSO JOINING US IS CAITLIN
POLANTZ.
WHERE TO BEGIN.
LET'S START WITH THE TAXES
DEBATE.
TRUMP HAS FOUGHT FOR YEARS.
HE KEPT SAYING HE WOULD RELEASE.
HE HAS FOUGHT TO KEEP THEM
PRIVATE.
THE HOUSE HAS THEM AND IN THE
TRUMP ORGANIZATION TRIAL UNDER
WAY IN NEW YORK RIGHT NOW, THE
TESTIMONY SAID THAT HE DIDN'T
PAY PERSONAL INCOME TAXES FOR A
LONG STRETCH OF TIME.
WHAT IS THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
THAT?
THE DEMOCRATS LOSE THE HOUSE IN
41 DAYS.
DOES IT MATTER THEY HAVE THESE
DOCUMENTS NOW?
>> THEY HAVE A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME IN WHICH TO TRI TO SAY WHAT
THEY THINK THIS MEANS AS FAR AS
LEGISLATION IS CONCERNED.
THAT'S WHAT THEY SAID THIS WAS
ABOUT, RIGHT?
THEY WANTED TO LOOK AT POSSIBLE
LEGISLATION ON AUDITING BY THE
IRS AND IT DOES RAISE QUESTIONS,
RIGHT, OF WHY THIS HAS BEEN --
WHAT THE FORMER PRESIDENT SAYS,
THERE HAS BEEN THIS LONG-RUNNING
AUDIT BUT LEARNED FROM THAT
TESTIMONY YESTERDAY THAT GOING
BACK TO 2010 AND YEARS
AFTERWARDS HE WAS CLAIMING THESE
HUGE NUMBER -- SUMS OF LOSSES
WHICH MEANT THAT HE DIDN'T
PAY -- HE WASN'T PAYING TAXES ON
THOSE NUMBERS.
AND THAT HAS BECOME -- THAT'S
GOING TO BE A BIG PART OF WHAT
LETITIA JAMES IS GOING,
ESSENTIALLY HE WAS FUDGING
NUMBERS TO AVOID PAYING TAXES.
>> THIS ALSO GIVES YOU A LITTLE
FINALITY OF THE LONG ARC OF
HOUSE POWER.
THE HOUSE IS GETTING TAX RETURNS
AFTER PURSUING THEM FOR THREE
YEARS IN COURT.
AND YOU'RE ALSO SEEING THE END
OF THIS HOUSE SELECT COMMITTEE
PARTICULARLY POWERFUL
INVESTIGATING THEIR OWN BODY, AN
ATTACK ON THEIR OWN BODY.
FOR THEM TO GET STUFF RIGHT IN
THE NICK OF TIME REALLY
UNDERLINES THE POWER OF
CONGRESS.
>> THE OTHER CASE, ONE OF THE
OTHER CASES, MAR-A-LAGO
DOCUMENTS AND THE IDEA THE
HEARING, THE THREE JUDGES IN THE
11th CIRCUIT, DO YOU NEED A
SPECIAL MASTER?
IS THAT NECESSARY?
WHAT IS THE SIGNIFICANCE IF THEY
SAY NO?
>> THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THIS CASE
GOES FAR BEYOND THIS PARTICULAR
SEARCH AND THAT'S WHY I THINK
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
PUSHING SO HARD TO GET AN APPEL
YACHT COURT TO THROW OUT THE
SPECIAL MASTER BECAUSE AT ITS
CORE, ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS THE
SUBJECT OF INVESTIGATION WHO IS
THE SUBJECT OF A PHYSICAL SEARCH
THAT THE FBI CONDUCTS PERSON TO
A WARRANT OBTAINED ON A PROBABLE
CAUSE FROM A FEDERAL JUDGE WHICH
IS WHAT HAPPENED IN THIS CASE,
EACH INDIVIDUAL WHO IS IN THAT
SITUATION ACROSS THE COUNTRY
DOES NOT GET A SPECIAL MASTER
APPOINTED TO THEIR CASE TO
REVIEW THE DOCUMENTS AND THAT'S
THE ARGUMENTS THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS MAKING IS THAT IN
THIS CASE THE JUDGE ORDERED THE
SPECIAL MASTER, GAVE FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP BASICALLY A
SPECIAL PRIVILEGE, TREATED HIM
DIFFERENTLY THAN ANYBODY ELSE
WOULD BE TREATED AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT NEEDS TO THINK ABOUT
ALL THE OTHER NATIONAL SECURITY
INVESTIGATIONS AND REGULAR
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS WHERE
THEY DON'T WANT THAT PRECEDENT
SET AND THAT'S WHY I THINK ALSO
THE 11th CIRCUIT IS OPEN TO
THESE ARGUMENTS THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS MAKING.
>> THE CHIEF JUDGE SAYS BECAUSE
DONALD TRUMP HAS FORMER
PRESIDENT BEFORE HIS NAME, OTHER
THAN THE FACT THIS INVOLVES A
FORMER PRESIDENT EVERYTHING ELSE
ABOUT THIS IS INDISTINGUISHABLE.
WE'VE GOT TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE PRECEDENT THAT WE WOULD
CREATE.
THAT'S TO CARRIE'S POINT THAT,
YOU KNOW, IF THEY COME TO MY
HOUSE AND SERVE A LEGAL SEARCH
WARRANT CAN I TIE UP THE SYSTEM
FOR MONTHS AND MONTHS FIGHTING?
>> BY THE WAY, WHEN HE WAS
PRESIDENT, THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
HE WAS ABLE TO DO.
HE WAS SUCCESSFUL IN BEING ABLE
TO DO THAT AND THAT WAS A BIG
THEME OF THE HEARING YESTERDAY.
THE TWO JUDGES WHO PREVIOUSLY
RULED AGAINST HIM AND EVEN THE
JUDGE THAT WE WERE WATCHING --
>> IN TWO OF THE THREE ARE TRUMP
APPOINTEES.
>> RIGHT, EXACTLY BUT WHAT WAS A
BIG THEME WAS TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM
KEPT SAYING THEY DIDN'T WANT
SPECIAL TREATMENT BUT THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT HE'S LOOKING FOR
AND WHAT THE JUDGE IN FLORIDA
GAVE HIM AND SO THAT'S THE
REASON WHY I THINK YOU HEARD A
LOT OF SKEPTICISM FROM THESE
THREE JUDGES YESTERDAY SAYING,
YOU KNOW, YOU'RE NOT SPECIAL.
YOU KNOW, AFTER ALL AND SO YOU
CAN'T EXPECT THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO BE TREATED DIFFERENTLY AND
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE YOU'RE THE
ONE THAT COMMINGLED CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS WERE PERSONAL ITEMS SO
THAT'S NOT THE GOVERNMENT'S
FAULT.
>> ANOTHER PERSON WHO FOUGHT AND
FOUGHT AND FOUGHT, YOU'LL NOTICE
THE THEME, TO TRY TO REFUSE
TESTIFYING WAS LINDSEY GRAHAM
WHO DID HAVE TO TESTIFY IN
FULTON COUNTY, GEORGIA.
WE KNOW FROM THE FORMER
SECRETARY OF STATE, THE CURRENT
ONE, BRAD RAFFENSPERGER GOT A
CALL, WE KNOW ABOUT THE CALL
FROM DONALD TRUMP.
CAN WE FIND 11,000 VOTES AND
CHANGE.
HE SAYS HE GOT A CALL FROM LIND
I GRAHAM, LISTEN.
>> AN IMPLICATION THAT, LOOK
HARD AND SEE HOW MANY BALLOTS
YOU COULD THROW OUT.
>> SO HOW IMPORTANT IS THIS
TESTIMONY IN THE, OKAY, LINDSEY
GRAHAM MADE THE CALL, THAT'S
WELL DOCUMENTED.
WOULDN'T THE QUESTION BEFORE THE
GRAND JURY BE WHO ASKED YOU TO
MAKE THAT CALL?
>> WE DON'T KNOW KNOW WHAT
LINDSEY GRAHAM ANSWERED.
THERE'S LOTS OF WAYS HE WAS ABLE
TO DECLINE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
AND HE WAS ALREADY SET UP BY THE
SUPREME COURT.
THEY SAID, YOU KNOW, WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BLOCK YOUR TESTIMONY IN
FULL.
YOU DO HAVE TO SHOW UP BUT HE
CAN STILL COME BACK TO COURT IF
HE WANTS TO.
THE GEORGIA GRAND JURY CAN TAKE
HIM TO COURT AND TRY TO LITIGATE
THESE THINGS.
IT TAKES TIME TO WORK THAT OUT
ESPECIALLY WITH PEOPLE IN
PROTECTED POSITIONS, ELECTED
OFFICIALS WHERE SPEECH OR DEBATE
CLAUSE, SORRY, RELATED TO
CONGRESS WOULD APPLY AROUND
THEM.
BUT GRAHAM IS IN A DIFFERENT
POSITION THAN TRUMP, RIGHT?
TRUMP IS HAVING ISSUES, GO TO
THE SUPREME COURT IN THEIR LAST
ROUNDS, THAT HE'S GETTING SOME
SORT OF FINALITY NOW.
THERE IS A FORCE FIELD THAT'S
FALLING AROUND THEM.
PEOPLE ARE TESTIFYING, SO EVEN
IF GRAHAM DOESN'T GIVE ANSWERS,
THERE MAY BE OTHERS WHO WOULD BE
ABLE TO FILL IN THE BLANKS THAT
GRAHAM IS UNWILLING TO ANSWER
TO.
>> AND I THINK, YOU KNOW, THE
OTHER TAKEAWAY FROM THIS IS THAT
A SITTING SENATOR TESTIFIED
PURSUANT TO LEGAL POSSESS AFTER
EXHAUSTING HIS LEGAL REMEDIES
AND THE SKY DIDN'T FALL.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING WHETHER IT
COMES TO THE 11th CIRCUIT
LOOKING AT OTHER CASES OR THE
RELEASE OF THE TAX RECORDS OR
WHETHER IT COMES TO THE FACT
THAT THE SENATOR FINALLY DID
GIVE TESTIMONY AND ANSWER
QUESTIONS IS THAT SOME OF THE
OTHER INSTITUTIONS AND THE COURT
IN PARTICULAR ARE HOLDING THEM
UP.